he has a egret
don't come out and think you're going to
crank this thing just leave it there
and turn your body turn your body
see i'm turning my body you see that
just hold it there just check it so it
doesn't hit you in the face
and then turn your body
and eventually it can't go anymore
so i'm gonna take a foot maneuver
you see that i don't want to do it here
we're going to do ishiro tencon
get him out of the turtle and now it's
on right
let's make it a game right now hold it
hold it on d turn your body
that's about as far that's the most
reaction i can get out of his grip
without doing this so i don't do that
here i am
there it turned then deal with
his turtleneck
and it's on at the completion
auditor's drive boom
turn boom get him off his knee
penny turn your body
flip maneuver there it's over then
you don't want people turtled on you
with the body turn
boom turn it's over then off
[Music]
okay so i'm not trying to be stronger
than him and turn this thing
i just hold it right right there and i
turn my body
and it'll turn on itself
that turn to gets me into this striking
range
and gets me out of the way of the cross
lateral hand
okay then i'm going to come over here
over the elbow and grab his wrist
so i'm going to show you that this is
where the kazushi is
this one
it's very hard to get that balance here
but this part of his arm has to go
boom in that pattern
don't focus on trying to hurt him
if you break his arm you're going to
lose the levers we don't attack the
joint
even though it's locked meaning he can't
use
he can't go various places they're
closed off in the trap
but it's not the mechanics that i'm
using
to disturb his balance okay so
hold out of the way and
right onto the wrist and i make the
wrist move
then here's where he
[Music]
that's the
i don't want to go back this way keep on
going forward
[Music]
boom
everything
i'm taking that hand off so you can see
right here
so that that's the technique and
even though i am uh i'm touching here
and i'm touching here
i really just using this
this part that's what i'm doing
because that's what takes him outside
his face
i'm going to put everything back in
place don't change any of the feelings
always just drawing the wrist
not fighting his elbow
the point of these grabs in many ways
is how not to clinch he's clinching
i'm trying to figure out this puzzle
how do i get around everything so
not fighting back go around
not trying pressure uses
balance
his arms are shorter than me and so the
tendency is when you wanted to
manipulate the elbow
you didn't prioritize the wrist so
always let
the hand go to the wrist that's where it
goes
and wherever i am on the arm it doesn't
matter
because the kazushi's out here
won't pop always to the wrist
don't prioritize the elbow so you're way
off here to the wrist
always don't overshoot it always to the
wrist and where i end up is where i end
up on his arm
it will still be an efficient lock at
the bottom
okay so in the same concept that i
i'm not fighting him as he starts to get
up
don't shove this down don't go to a
different version with more weight
everything is in place he starts to push
up against you
just roll it and you're in nico
okay
that's why this grip is important it's
now in the nico grip
so when he starts to fight it he's
starting to lift up he's stronger than
me
you just yield and there it is
boom you're in nico you'll feel the
pressure
and yield to it time it
find it it's all in place here he goes
to fight you
let him up boom and you really
the point of the lesson is not to fight
him not to
grapple wrestle him
okay so he he i'm going
and working inside the holes of his
technique
okay there's i'm not fighting anyone
there's no fight over here
and i just go outside his face
he falls down now as he starts to get up
go ahead this doesn't make any sense
if i get up with him in a way
i don't have to do anything he's doing
it i don't do anything i move myself to
be in the right place
just like i did here
don't go here just hold
and turn it turns on its own then move
now he's gonna get up and i'm just
yielding
to what he's doing
so
[Music]
hey